hi there steve here again this is sort
of an
not part of my regular uh
scheduled videos i just want to sort of
uh let you know why there were those 14
videos put up where i talk about
uh you know
language learning this is part of a
course that uh
we make available to people who
subscribe to
my blog the linguistic language the
linguist blog i think it is we'll put
the actual link in the description box
uh it's a series of emails with these
videos that are supposed to motivate
people
and give them a sense of how to go about
learning languages
and you know i'm always surprised at how
most people still think they have to go
to a school they have to follow the
traditional way of learning last night i
was at a reception in a pub here in
vancouver
uh
organized by ciaspo lanstitut politik
which is the school that i went to in
paris and they have an exchange program
with ubc
whereby some french students come here
to vancouver some
ubc students go to france
they have to obviously
learn french or should although i gather
the courses which are given in haas
[Music]
rather than in paris
many of them are in english
which
to some degree defeats the purpose of
going to france to study but
they all seem to look upon language
learning as something well we'll have to
take a course in this take a course on
that get a credit for the language and
it all relates around credits and
and rather than how to get into language
learning enjoy it and
and learn things through the language
and you're if you're going to france to
study at sean's poll why do it in
english do it in french and learn all
these things through the language and
improve your language
at any rate so i think it is important
to get the message out that there is
another way to learn languages hence
this course and of course it is tied to
helping explain to people how to use
link which again
many people don't understand the site so
since we also have a series of
sort of instructional videos on how to
use link which i didn't release
with the original 14 i've decided now
that i will also put those up on my site
so they'll also be in a playlist and if
you're interested you can have a look at
this series of videos on how to get the
most out of link so that's just to let
you know what's going on and i'll
continue my regular series of videos uh
early next week bye for now
[Music]
you